so these are two pictures of the same
figure this is a front view
of the object and this is the back view
of the object and if a unit cube looks
like this
what i want to do is i want to figure
out the volume of this figure in terms
of unit cubes or in terms of cubic units
i encourage you to pause the video and
think of it on your own before we we try
it together
all right well there's a bunch of ways
that we could tackle this all of them
kind of breaking this figure up in
different ways one way we could do it we
could break it up into
this
i guess we could call it a rectangular
prism
so
if you could see through there would be
like this so this piece right over here
this piece right over here and i'll
redraw it here so you can visualize it
so if i were to redraw it it looks like
this
it looks like
this and what are its
what are its dimensions
well it's four
four units wide
it's two units high
and then it's four units we could say
long or four units deep so just like
that and so what's the volume of this
yellow part
well the volume is just you multiply
these three dimensions the length times
the width times the height so the volume
is going to be our length
times our width times our height
4 times 4
is 16 times 2 is 32 but we're not done
that's just the volume of this yellow
part we still have to take into
consideration the volume of this piece
right over here that we haven't figured
out yet
this piece
right over there and this one might just
jump out at you you could just count the
unit cubes but i'll i'll redraw it here
just to show you what's going on
all right so it looks like this
it looks like this
and what are its dimensions
well it's too wide too high and we could
say one deep or one long and so its
volume is going to be equal to
your length or i could say well your
length
times your width times your height which
is equal to four and you just see that
there's one two three four unit cubes in
this object so the total volume is going
to be 32
plus
plus 4 is equal to 36. now of course
there's other ways to tackle it you
could just say hey let's figure out the
volume of the blue layer and then just
double it because that red layer has the
same volume as the blue layer
and the blue layer you could say well
look it's only one deep so we just have
to count the cubes up here and then
we'll know how many unit cubes fit into
it so you literally could just count
one two let me do the color you could
actually see you just have to go one two
three four five six seven eight nine 10
11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18.
so you see there are 18 cubes in the
blue layer and then there's another go
they're going to be another 18 in the
red layer
plus 18 that also gets you to 36 unit
cubes or a volume of 36 cubic units